6 24 on your wednesday morning if all
you want to know is when is the 95 515
gonna get back to whatever normal is a
new website from the nevada department
of transportation is driving home the
point that
gonna be a while it's called
nv515.com and it shows that what we're
in the middle of right now is just part
of six different projects that may
stretch into the year 2030.
so the big squeeze that's eventually
going to be completely overshadowed by
what's called the downtown access
project that's going to completely
rebuild the entire freeway between the
spaghetti well and eastern that's the
one that could take you into the turn of
the decade but there's plenty more early
next year current plans call for almost
two years worth of repaving on the 95
515 down around the 215 then late next
year ndot's planning to redo just about
everything around the freeway at
charleston sometime in 2023 it'll be
what's sometimes called the henderson
bowl due for a two-year-long makeover
last but not least a bunch of work
around the 95 515 at flamingo is on the
calendar for
2025. oh boy the link to all of these
projects is in the online version of
this story on our website eight newsnow
dot com click traffic then driving you
crazy
good luck buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone something's
driving me crazy the email address
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com